und wir schauen auf einen unfassbaren
vandalismus in dresden es geht um uralte
unbezahlbare kunst aus aller welt kommen
menschen um diese gemälde zu sehen und
jetzt beschädigt mutwillig und sie hatte
ihre finger im spiel wir sehen hier die
festnahme einer jungen frau maike g ist
das 21 jahre jung sie wird von zwei
polizisten aus dem berühmten gemälde
galerie alte meister begleitet und in
den streifenwagen gesetzt eine klima
chaoten offenbar nichts zurückschreckt
ja und das dass es ihr vergehen
gemeinsam mit anderen mitgliedern der
letzten generation steht sie vor der
sixtinischen madonna klebt sich dort an
den berühmtesten gemälde der welt kann
man fast schon sagen fest dort mit ihrem
kollegen posten diese aktion stolz dann
auf ihrem twitter-kanal dass es ein sehr
anderes berühmtes gemälde des
renaissance künstlers raffael zu
bewundern viele menschen viele touristen
und viele aus deutschland in dresden er
wegen der kleber aktionen die
gemäldegalerie für besucher gesperrt
werden das liebste das bild selbst blieb
unbeschädigt der rahmen ebenfalls
natürlich uralt natürlich nicht vor der
galerie alte meister steht jetzt unser
bild reporter bernhard schilz bernhard
kannst du uns schülern was genau da
passiert ist vor allem was mit dem
gemälde passiert ist wie groß die
schäden sind
ja das war heute genau um 12 uhr da sind
also drei klimaaktivisten in die
gemäldegalerie gegangen haben ganz
normal tickets gekauft für sich und
haben sich dann der sixtinischen madonna
genährt zwei haben sich dann festgeklebt
am rahmen und der dritte hat die ganze
aktion gefilmt die wachleute hier sind
sofort eingeschritten aber da clique der
kleber schon und wir wissen inzwischen
dass dieser rahmen wurde erst erstellt
zum 500-jährigen jubiläum vor zehn
jahren die sixtinische madonna und er
wurde bestätigt die staatlichen
kunstsammlungen hat es im klebereste
dran die restauratoren werden sich jetzt
den schaden anschauen um festzustellen
wie
das restauriert werden kann
das sagte gallery zu dieser aktion heute
mussten ja die türen auch erstmal
geschlossen werden kann man den schaden
schon in irgendeiner höhe beziffern der
schaden ist noch nicht beziffert die
galerie war jetzt satte drei stunden
geschlossen auch durch die
spurensicherung der polizei und
befragung von zeugen
die galerie sagt ja sie haben schon die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen verschärft deswegen
war ein wachmann direkt neben dem
gewählt man darf auch keine taschen mit
die galerie nehmen aber sie sagt die
pressesprecherin sagte uns ja so eine
tube sekundenkleber den kann man auch im
bh verstecken und somit kann man das
nicht völlig ausschließen dass so ein
anschlag passiert
während du sprichst die festnahme ist es
mit den beiden kleber aktivisten dann
geschehen genau so der der nur gefilmt
hat und
fotografiert hat den haben dass man
quasi links liegen gelassen er wurde des
raumes verwiesen die beiden anderen sind
hier von den polizeibeamten abgeführt
worden nicht in handschellen aber in den
streifenwagen verbracht zur vernehmung
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen
gemeinschädlicher sachbeschädigung weil
es sicherheit um ein kulturgut ein über
500 jahre altes gemälde handelt also ihm
droht jetzt dort ein
ermittlungsverfahren strafanzeige will
die spd stellen das ganze ist auch eine
solidaritätsaktion gewesen weil vor
wenigen tagen ja ein deutscher aktivist
in stockholm sogar für eine kleber
aktion auf der straße in haft genommen
worden ist
[Musik]